the the number one killer of these
multi-founder companies
is infighting between the founders you
don't see that typically in a solo
founder but with the solo founder of the
solo founder
you know loses their mind
jumps the fence now you got a problem
because who's going to run the company
so i don't over optimize for this
i think it's stupid to over optimize for
it i'm not saying program stupid for
doing it he had a reason to do it
it was like a mechanical technical
reason and he was doing 100 startups it
makes total sense there
what i'm trying to say here is what i
there's so many more that there's so
many more
important things to think about with a
startup
how good is the idea how good is the
execution of that idea in other words
how good is the product
how much do the customers love that
product will the customers
be absolutely distraught if the cost if
the product goes away
like if tesla went away tomorrow
i don't know what car i drive i go back
to driving a corvette i mean
i i would be i would be heartbroken if i
couldn't drive my tesla right
and a lot of people feel that way about
their iphones or their uber or their
postmates or their airbnb like
that's how good the product has to be so
focus on that
i don't care you want to be one the only
problem i do have is when there's like
five
because then who's in charge and then
how much equity is left
so then that becomes a math problem solo
founder
gets diluted 20 20 20 20
okay somewhere along the line they own
20 of the company when it goes public
right
or something in that range you get five
co-founders okay
you know vcs come in and take 30 percent
five co-found
they give 10 to the employees five
co-founders have 12 percent each
then they get diluted 20 so they're down
to 10 percent
they're down to seven percent and you
know when you start getting founders
into the low single digits you know what
they start thinking
if i start over and i'm a solo founder i
can have 85 percent of this
bleep in company and i've seen it happen
and it's a real bummer so you gotta top
off those founders i have a little
secret for that
because i'm usually early in and i'm the
early advocate i'll just say to the
latest stage founders
the later stage investors listen this
founder is
at i don't know in one case it was like
i don't know 11
i'm like this kid's killing himself he's
got 11 percent of the company
the company had to raise money it was a
pretty hard situation
he doesn't have a co-founder but i want
to give this founder five points over
five years
people were like oh my lord i'm like
well he's almost fully vested
you want to run the company and we'll
put the five points and we'll tie it to
something like performance or whatever
and i got everybody to do it then i was
in another situation happened to be a
female founder
she was down below 20 percent you know i
think she wasn't as
acute as the 10 situation she was at
like 15.
she wants to do the top off she says i
want 10 more i went on 25
she had just taken a couple million
dollars i'm i'm blurring some of the
details here so it's not identifiable
and i said okay i support you but
you know there's two other there's two
other board members you have to win
over with this thing and so she said
will you talk to the board member i
talked to the board member he's hardcore
he's like
no no
um hit your numbers for a year and then
make a request you still have
18 months left on your vest when this
investment when you're
through this vesting schedule and you've
hit
this millions of dollars in revenue then
i think you can make that request and i
was like okay
for me i'm like i just want to lock the
founder in i don't want them looking
over their shoulder so great question i
gave you a little more information than
you asked for
but no jason at caliconus.com
doesn't care if you're solo or two or
three and my point about the raul story
is
lo and behold he started another company
called superhuman
there are other partners there but he's
running the show basically
um and i think he's kind of a solo
founder um
although there might be some folks who
consider themselves like on the founding
team
so there's a lot of like um nuance to
this as well
the way you know who the founder is is
there somebody who owns 30 or 40
of the company that's like a solo
founder and if there's two or three they
own
you know typically 10 or 20 each which
can be a lot of money if you stick
around